[Music]
hey very good morning to you this is uh
Ian King live I'm Wilfred Frost in for
Ian today bringing you an hour of
business and economic news from the
heart of the city of London snow strikes
Rising Energy prices and economic Gloom
have had a dramatic effect on the UK
economy GDP data out this morning shows
the UK economy recorded zero growth
between October and December last year
the ons numbers are Stark economic
growth in the fourth quarter of last
year zero percent in line though with
economists expectations but the UK
dodged a recession thanks to gains at
the start of the quarter the chancellor
has been giving his reaction to our
business correspondent Paul Kelso
so is there any circumstance in which
you would consider higher pay
settlements for those public sector
workers who are struggling with
circumstances which your government and
predecessors have helped create well um
we have invested record sums in the NHS
in our schools and we want to back them
to the help because they have a very
very important job to do for the country
and we'll talk about absolutely anything
to resolve these strikes accept measures
that would entrench High inflation and
we don't think strikes are helpful
they're very damaging they're very
disruptive we think the best way to
resolve these issues is to sit and talk
and find a solution that doesn't
entrench the very inflation that is
upsetting so many people plenty of
economists will say that there's no
danger of wage price spiral from public
sector wage are you saying there is no
more money forget it get back to work
there's no chance of an increased payoff
well we should listen to the very clear
warning from the bank of England
Governor yesterday who said that if you
fund higher wage settlements through
borrowing that is inflationary and
that's why it's a very difficult
situation we want to get in back into a
situation where people's real wages are
growing but the one thing that we
shouldn't do if we want that to happen
is to do something that digs in this
High inflation so is that a no to more
money it's not a no it's saying we'll
talk about absolutely anything except
things that will dig in the very high
inflation that is causing people to see
the the cost of their weekly shop go up
and the value of their wages erode as
well as
below inflation pay Rises if you're in
the public sector people also facing
across the board huge pressure on energy
bills you're about to put energy bills
up by withdrawing support in April
wholesale gas prices are falling this is
not as expensive as you would have
initially thought is there any way
you'll reconsider that withdrawal of
support and give people help with energy
bills through the spring but we are
doing absolutely everything we can to
help families through this difficult
period we're giving about three and a
half thousand pounds of support on
average to every family in the country
this year and last year so it's it's a
massive amount of help about 99 billion
pounds but we also have to be
responsible with public finances because
if we're not we just give them a
different pressure Which is higher
interest rates so you won't reconsider
that well we look at everything we can
do but we won't do things that leads to
higher interest rates because that just
creates a different pressure
joining me now Victoria Clarke UK Chief
Economist at Santander thanks so much
for joining me Victoria so I mean the
headline here is maybe it's a
technicality but recession is avoided it
is recessions avoided perhaps for now
perhaps not and the you know the picture
is that things look a bit better than we
might have feared they would be six
months ago so we've avoided having a
second consecutive quarter of GDP
falling so we've avoided that technical
Factor but you know GDP basically hasn't
grown the economy hasn't grown in size
through through the whole of the year I
mean if you look at the level of GDP
it's exactly the same at the end of
December as where it was December before
well not just versus a year before but
if if you compare across the G20 to
pre-pandemic levels in absolute terms as
opposed to percentage growth we are
still below pre-pandemic levels exactly
in the UK is the relative underperformer
there so we're smaller than our
pre-pandemic size and that is the work
of inflation but of course you know
there has been inflation globally and
and there is you know clearly a story of
the UK economy suffering a little bit
more than elsewhere through you know
through 2022. so clearly today we got
the full quarters growth numbers uh in
the books uh December the latest
addition to that within the quarter the
quarter was saved by the first couple of
months December was quite a depressing
uh Outlook that's right so October
November were okay November was helped
because of the World Cup and that
boosted lots of spending in in pubs and
bars and then we got into December and
the economy shrunk and it shrunk by
about excuse me about half a percent on
in GDP and that was because of a big
drop in Services output and that came as
the Health Service in particular was
impacted by strikes because of snow as
well which perhaps meant that there
wasn't as much attendance in education
and it was these sorts of one of factors
that probably mean that December is not
quite as bad as those headlines suggest
so just expand for me a bit on that that
point and and how tangible is it that
strikes are a big factor in that paw
print of December's I think that they
they are a factor you can see that in
the you know in the drop in health
activity and the drop-in appointments
for doctors and nurses which you can see
in the numbers
um but beneath the surface still I mean
it's quite likely that if you took that
out GDP was probably a bit lower in
December than it was and I think you
know this comes back to what's the you
know what's the bigger picture when you
take out all of these odd factors the
World Cup delays and Premiership
football matches all these things which
are quirks of the numbers and it's that
you know we're not growing the growth is
not there that's largely because of
inflation because you know if you look
at what we call economists called
consumer facing Services things that
people might be more careful about going
out and buying and things they do face
to face space they're much much weaker
than they were before the pandemic and
inflation is driving you know huge bus
down the middle of what you could buy in
in the amount of spending that you would
do and what you get in terms of how much
you can actually take home at the High
Street and the government Bank of
England earlier this week at least came
out with some less pessimistic uh
rhetoric on inflation about it coming
down in the year ahead to what extent
has most of the pain been taken when it
comes to tightening monetary policy
perhaps most of the pain when it comes
to strikes as well I asked whether or
not from here things might just start to
improve for the government from a low
base so I think that the challenge for
this coming year is monetary policy
because we've had a hell of a lot of
rate Rises through the last year and
most of that impact is still to be felt
on people that are coming to refinance
their mortgages at you know rates that
will be much higher they may have
refinanced them at two percent they
might be looking now to refinance at say
four percent so there is a big squeeze
on household spending for those
households that come to face that and
that's you know that's the big question
looking to this year probably more
inflation for six months so a continued
stagnation from that and then you add
the impact of interest rate Rises and I
think this is what the bank of England's
becoming quite worried about is that it
you know it has a sense of how how that
might slow the economy it's quite
difficult to be precise about that and
they are worried about overcooking the
extent of the rate Rises and just just
finally as we said recession avoided
perhaps that was better than we would
have thought three to six months ago how
did Q4 in December compare to say the US
and Continental Europe so I think the UK
has performed relatively poorly again
same picture versus its peers I mean
part of that was the weather um part of
its it's the strikes but I think you
know in you know in the US in in the
Eurozone actually it looks as if things
may have been a bit better I think they
were slightly better than better than
they were in the UK so we do seem to be
consistently at this point coming out of
the bottom of that pack Victoria o'clock
thanks so much for joining me thank you
uh some other stories uh making the news
this morning now the boss of AstraZeneca
the second largest company in the ftse
100 has said they chose to build a new
manufacturing plant in Ireland because
of what he called discouraging tax rates
in the UK chief executive suaro said
ministers were making what he called
glib claims about Britain becoming a
science superpower the new research
facility was part of a 360 million
dollar investment by the drugs
manufacturer
ofcom has launched a review of
mid-contract phone and Broadband price
Rises the regulator says a third of
customers don't know their provider can
increase the cost of their bills during
their deal it says it's concerned about
the degree of uncertainty people are
facing over inflation linked price Rises
there's a big boost for the UK High
Street this morning it's a new flagship
store from a major Global retailer opens
Swiss firm on has unlocked the doors of
its Central London shop just months
after a multi-million dollar flotation
on the New York Stock Exchange which
valued the company at nearly at 750
million dollars in fact I think they
raised 750 million dollars we can speak
with Bianca pestilotti yeah Europe
Middle East and Africa general manager
four on running who is in the new store
in Regent Street uh this morning well
congrats on the the store opening it
looks like it's already pretty busy
behind you
thanks a lot yes we're very excited
about the opening of the store we opened
a couple of minutes ago and it's already
bustling with uh with people who are
coming in to shop with us so we're very
excited about Richard Street and and
just uh for those of us that that or
those that don't know
um exactly what what uh what is the
brand it's clearly running equipment and
it started as director consumer is is
that is that fair to say or at least
with an online focus but but you're
obviously opening a flagship uh physical
store today
so we're a performance running brand
from Switzerland we've always had a
strong e-com business as as you've
mentioned but we have a multi-channel
distribution so we work with wholesale
partners and we also have our own retail
stores just like the one in in region
street that I'm currently in a select
few around the world and the London
flagship store is our first Flagship
location in Europe outside of our homes
yeah and and I guess it's not just a
store this it's it's as you kind of
alluded to you've got workouts rooms as
well it's a place for you for your
customers to actually spend quite a lot
of time
exactly we believe that customer is in
the current Retail Landscape they shop
online for convenience but they come to
stores for more of an immersive
experience with the brand so at on
London Shoppers can touch feel
experiment with the product with our
sustainability projects such as the
Cyclone program they can find the broad
broadest range of on product across
Footwear and apparel that they'll find
anywhere in London and it's also a hub
for us to interact with our community to
host runs and to to interact with
Runners to have our athletes and coaches
here to take our fans for runs so all of
this is what you'll find at the at the
region Street store and we look forward
to welcoming many of you to the store
and and to just talk talk me through
when the decision was made to open such
a a prime location store uh in in London
I mean many people of course noted how
much rents fell during the pandemic
they've recovered a bit but but is it
still only possible because they're
lower than say they would have been five
years ago or or was this just on the
cards no matter what
but it's true that we we started
investing into our own retail stores
during the pandemic but for us it was
really a focus on delivering a very
interactive experience to our to our
customers London is an important city
for us in Europe it's our number one
city when it comes to d2c customers in
the region so the decision to make
London a focus to really build a hub for
our community on on region street that
was the important one when we started
looking for for store locations in
London and the UK as a market has been
one of our fastest growing markets and
and therefore remains a priority for the
brand and this is why I'm really excited
about the store opening today and and
just finally Bianca's sum up the brand
for us is it is it really for elite high
performance Runners only
so we'll be a brand for for high
performance Runners um we have products
like our Cloud boom Echo
um that marathon runners triathletes are
winning races in but of course we are
also speaking to everybody out there
who's moving and who's active whether
this is in running or in different forms
of workouts and the londoners in
particular they're they're very active
they're Avid Runners but they also just
live a very active life
um so so this is why we're excited to to
meet as many people as possible in
London in our region Street store and
across the other stores that we have in
the city Bianca thanks so much for
joining us congrats on the store opening
this morning thank you
and now after a huge boom figures out
today suggests the current global
economic difficulties are now hitting
the UK used car market the number of
sales last year fell by 8.5 percent the
rising number of deals on electric
vehicles was the only source of optimism
within the numbers so joining me now
auto traders commercial director uh Ian
Plummer uh Ian thanks so much for for
joining me I guess just before we dive
into the details give us some context of
the years or year before last year
because the 8.5 decline comes uh after a
decent couple of years for for used car
sales
but I think that context is absolutely
vital because what you're seeing today
is the result of in used cars what we
did or didn't build as a use as a new
car so we've had three years of new car
sales that have been roughly 1.6 million
or so but that compares to a long-term
average of around 2.4 and peaks of 2.6
even 2.7 million but quite simply we are
today in a supply constrained new but
also used car market demand levels are
very strong so without enough cars
coming into the new car market they're
not flowing through into the used car
Arena either but there is strong demand
pricing has been surging upwards very
strongly and more than 40 price increase
today compared to pre-pandemic times
unlike for like cars so you've got a
context which is very much Supply
constrained that actually quite healthy
despite what you you touched on in terms
of your introduction we think the market
is in a good shape
and and just just to expand on that
briefly so the the new cars were
particularly Supply constrained has that
eased a bit and therefore taken back
some of the demand from used cars
well the new car situation is is linked
back historically obviously to the fact
that the factories were closed during
covert areas
um the lockdown period affected
manufacturing quite significantly uh
Parts orders were canceled for key
components such as semiconductors you
then got into a price war with uh
sourcing of those semiconductors where
manufacturers were competing against uh
people selling tablets and laptops to
those of us in lockdowns and children
needing additional I.T equipment they
didn't get those semiconductors and they
still don't have enough sorry enough
those microchips right now today's who
fit them into their cars today's car
needs around 1500 semiconductors so
you've got a an awful lot of Kit in the
in in in a typical Car double lap for a
high value uh electric vehicle and quite
simply that's constrained production you
added to that in the last year or so the
the issues relating to Ukraine also for
the Kobe lockdowns in China That's
What's led to lack of new car production
but quite simply if you don't build a
new car it doesn't become a used car it
doesn't enable somebody to bring back a
car as a part exchange when they're
buying another one would be new or used
and you slow down the whole market so
the pricing Dynamic is one of the key
things that's changed there but the used
car Arena naught to five-year-old cars
is back around 27 in terms of available
stock and what it was
um pre-pandemic times
so so
um touch on the the trend underneath and
particular EV sales obviously we know
demand has spiked for for new EVS what's
it like in the in the used uh car market
well EVS are a bright spot have you
touched on there is strong demand for
electric vehicles um it's been growing
strongly through the last year or two
it's been boosted by announcements such
as you know the political announcement
to cut the sale of the of petrol and
diesel vehicles that saw a huge surge of
interest on those uh on those cars on
our platform
um that continued through uh
difficulties to actually get petrol at
pumps that was October or so of 21 then
price increases of petrol and so on the
energy price increased was more likely
has dampened a little bit of the demand
boost that we've been seeing at the same
time a supply of electric vehicles just
come surging through of used vehicles
they've they've come off fleets and
they're coming back as part exchanges
now which is great to see that is now
leading though to a a like a crossing of
the lines between the supply curve and
the demand curve so pricing electric is
coming down in many ways that's a good
thing because the affordability issue of
electric is quite certainly a blocker
for demand
it's a challenge for the industry but
fundamentally I think what we're seeing
more broadly in the market is is really
strong demand for automotive so we're
seeing for example in the month of
January the visits to AutoTrader are up
hugely up to a record level of 80
million uh visits to the platform around
more than 10 million unique visitors to
the site so that's up around 14 on
January 2022. the blind this idea that
there's no sort of Health in the market
it's a supply constrained Market not a
demand reduced one and that's flowing
through we think into sales so our
indicative sales data for January for
used cars actually shows a growth of
around eight percent again very
different to the trend we saw we've
highlighted through a whole of 2022 and
signs that there's definitely an upturn
um coming through and dependent again on
the supply of the available vehicles I
mean just just finally um I know this is
a big factor for for the auto market in
in the US uh is it less so here the fact
that the interest rates have risen what
sort of percentage of people buy their
cars on a finance deal versus uh buy
them out right
um a growing number to be to be honest
with you so we assume that with pricing
having gone up as much as it has that
that's going to put a lot of people off
and it clearly we'll put off some people
that makes cars uh more challenging to
get into particularly if you're a
first-time buyer if you've got a car
you're bringing back a part exchange
which itself is of higher value and you
put that value down against the purchase
price of the new vehicle whether it be a
new or used car so you actually reduce
the the remaining amount that you've got
to finance in some way and actually
Finance sales have grown quite strongly
in the last year and more as more people
have seen Finance as a good tool to be
able to afford these maybe more more
highly costed Vehicles so the finance
rate has grown to around one in two used
car buyers buying Finance from the point
of sale the fun day with the car
retailer that they're working with so
it's seen as actually a great tool to
enable more people to get into a car
Ian thanks so much for joining me much
appreciated
thank you
so to come here on Ian King live we'll
take a look at how Global markets are
performing so far this morning
[Music]
welcome back let's have a look at how
the markets are doing firstly uh in Asia
or a soft end of the week particularly
for Hong Kong down a couple of percent
it's been a negative week overall for
Hong Kong and China after what was a
ferocious uh rally over the back end of
last year in the early part of this year
due to China's reopening just giving up
a bit of those gains of like the big
story in and around the bank of Japan
which we'll come to in just a moment on
the currency front but the Nikkei as you
can see up a fraction about a third of a
percent today a softer end of the week
appears to be on the cards for Europe as
well as you can see across the board
declines for Continental Europe uh
Germany in particular uh down a percent
uh in part because of a 10 decline for
Adidas who issued a profit warning last
night uh particularly related to some of
their celebrity endorsements uh one of
which very controversial the Yeezy uh
brand uh course tied to Kanye the other
less controversial but it's not doing
very well some other the celebrity
endorsement packages that they have that
closest to home in the UK the ftse 100
is down about 0.4 percent of course it's
been trading near all-time highs of late
uh and just giving up a little bit of
ground today of note their Standard
Chartered down five percent uh albeit
still up about five percent on the week
as a whole uh it's been uh some takeover
talk uh dominating uh the share price
moves for Standard Chartered over the
last week and uh some of the hot air
coming out today but still up on the
week as a whole attorney to currencies
uh as I said the focus uh on who might
lead the bank of Japan uh next uh coroda
due to step down in April and kazuo ueda
expected now to be named as uh the new
head of the bank of Japan initially we
did see the Yen jump uh it's now down
about a percent uh a lot of uncertainty
is exactly what he'll stand for it's a
little bit of an unknown uh choice but
you can see Sterling itself not doing
too much today 121 against the dollar
and a quick look at oil prices up a
couple of percent uh Brent though
remaining Range band in the mid 80s 86
well below where it was at the highs of
last year let's discuss uh all of this
uh now with the chief investment officer
at waverton Investment Management uh
Bill Denning Bill very good morning to
you thanks so much for joining me
um let's touch first of all just uh on
the UK ftse 100 as we know has been
trading near record highs we've got the
GDP data out this morning is that a big
swing factor for the ftse 100 or not
really I don't think so really because
the ftse 100 is really more about sort
of the global uh situation in terms of
demand you know it's the big
multinationals about two-thirds of ftse
100 earnings come from overseas on the
margin though there's slightly better
data in the UK is probably good for the
ftse 250 which had a terrible year last
year and I do think the UK has got some
support as a market just partly because
sentiment remains extremely gloomy about
the UK so I I think the UK it
outperformed last year and it might have
another good year what one factor of
course that people look at for markets
as a whole including here is what the
sort of dividend yield of the index is
like compared to where interest rates
are and is there some encouraging signs
that the bank of England well perhaps
won't be cutting rates anytime soon
might not have too many rate hikes left
in it well I think that's right and in
fact I think one of the things that's
been interesting about the market in in
the last few months has been the market
has been thinking that the Federal
Reserve is also quite close to the end
of its tightening cycle and the Market's
been very confident that in the United
States the FED would be cutting interest
rates the second half of the Year here
in the UK for a long time the market was
expecting the bank of England to get
rates up to about four and a half
percent and then stay there I think one
of the things that's interesting at the
moment is that actually that shifted a
little bit so Peak for the UK is more
like four and a quarter and there is an
expectation that the bank can probably
cut rates in the second half of the Year
whereas the confidence in how far the
FED can cut rates is is waning a little
bit so I think on the margin I think
that's right I think it probably is
helpful for the UK and if that has a
knock-on to to Sterling ief UK interest
rates aren't going up as much and might
start coming down that might be not
supportive for Sterling but then for the
economy that's not necessarily a bad
thing so let's touch on on the US it
sounds like therefore you have a
slightly more bearish view than perhaps
where consensus is and of course it
comes off quite a strong rally for you
us markets in in January yeah I think
our concern about the US is really a
what we were just saying I think the FED
is is fed's been making it very clear
they expect to keep interest rates
potentially at a higher level for longer
and I I think we sort of kind of think
that's probably quite realistic because
the UK economy the US economy at the
moment is is clearly quite robust and
domestic demand in the states does have
an impact on you U.S inflation UK
domestic demands impact on UK inflation
is less so I think in the US there's
concern about rates and I think the
other thing is the cycle is probably
rolling over in the states a lot of very
reliable indicators of of recessions in
the United States are flashing red
warning signals so we think that the U.S
economy could be weaker in the months
ahead but rates may have to stay higher
even because of the inflation backdrop
so that makes us a little bit cautious
let's touch on Asia and China in
particular clearly had a ferocious rally
at the back end of last year from low
levels uh on the back of of course the
reopening post-covered extend lockdown
story is that now priced in all the good
news or not uh probably not I mean
obviously as ever with with China it's a
little bit difficult to sort of really
read the signs of exactly what's
happening but I think that the two
angles I would I would suggest that are
probably got a long way to go yet is one
certainly if China does continue it's
it's sort of reopening and people are
going back to work then clearly
industrial production will pick up it
will be good for domestic incomes the
other side of it is if the Chinese are
traveling again that's a really good
thing for a number of countries in the
Asia region it's particularly good for a
country like Thailand and more broadly
it's quite good for sort of global
tourism so it can have a positive impact
on the global economy the only thing is
if the US is particularly slowing in the
U.S in particular slowing down whether
what China is doing it could be enough
to offset that I'm not so sure but yes
the China reopening I think has further
to go Bill thanks so much for joining me
thank you
uh still to come here on in King life
could college and university Sports
become the next Battleground in high
value Sports rights we'll discuss
[Music]
welcome back millions of people around
the world will watch the Super Bowl this
Sunday on TV tablets and smartphones the
rights for the NFL were recently sold
for 110 billion dollars and the sports
rights Market looks set to continue
growing Swedish firm spideo wants to
expand from its traditional work on
video replay analysis and into the
sports rights market and join me now is
the chief executive of spideo Patrick
Olsen who was also an influential figure
in the standardization of Bluetooth in
the early 2000s uh Patrick great to see
you thanks for joining me thank you very
much for having me so just talk us
through exactly what your your company
does this is outside of the Super Bowl
or the Premier League match this Sunday
it's for sports that's going on a couple
of levels below that exactly so
basically what we do is we automate the
process of capturing and producing
sports on video so essentially removing
the need for a cameraman and removing
the need for a big Sports Production
Studio
still we produce content that is Rich
has audio commentary overlays sponsor
Graphics scoreboards Etc but without any
human interaction and and so typically
if we're talking about lower Leagues
football here in in the UK it wouldn't
be filmed or produced to a high level
because the costs involved were too high
and you're able to do that exactly it's
affordable level basically what we do we
reduce the cost of production from
thousands of dollars per game to just a
few dollars per game and that opens up
an entirely New Market that hasn't been
available before we can now enable
millions of games to be available for
online viewing to viewers that weren't
able to watch these games in the past
and and your Partnerships then are with
the individual teams themselves as
opposed to the leagues how does it how
does it work mostly with rights holders
so there is a movement across the world
now where the media writes for this
mid-level Sports is being Acquired and
and that is because we have automatic
production so we can lower the cost of
the production and not all of a sudden
you can do pay-per-view sponsors ads and
things like that to monetize those
rights so here in the UK talk us through
some of your clients and and
Partnerships are with uh in the UK we
mostly have our video analysis customers
like Premier League teams and such but a
good example of this would be one of our
customers in Minnesota that does 20 000
ice hockey high school games per season
and they do that with a team of five
people so every weekend there are
hundreds of games running automatically
produced made available to the entire
ice hockey community in in Minnesota and
and Premier League teams here in the UK
do you have any of them and and if their
main TV rights obviously are already
tied up with the Premier League itself
and as on our sister channel on Sky
Sports for example what what can you do
with them if if they've already given
those rights away to Sky Sports yeah so
for those teams like Brentford listened
and such use our system they use our
system for video analysis so to
automatically capture trainings and
matches get live footage get live data
so that they can analyze and do
performance improvements during the game
after the game and during the training
and so on really interesting and so if
we step back from specifically what you
do for some of these teams what is your
view on the state of the market at the
moment essentially Sports rights have
just continued to to rise no matter what
the economic climate over over the last
two decades broadly speaking do you
think that will continue with similar
rates of inflation or as it's starting
to Plateau no it will definitely
continue the interesting thing is that
Sports Tech is now transforming all
parts of sports everything from
consumption to production to analysis to
experiences interactive interactive
experiences this will increase the value
of the rights that are out there on all
levels and and how much is that
inflation in the the price that
broadcasters pay for the live sports
tied to gambling and the way that that
has in general despite some laws being
passed in the UK in general continuing
to see liberalization particularly in
the U.S yeah definitely that's happening
and as you said there has been changing
in the U.S that will affect this as well
um and I think also the interactivity of
how you want to consume Sports in the
future we will not be looking at sports
from start to end anymore we will be
interacting with the game we'll be
tapping on players get that place live
bets and things like that it will change
the way that we consume Sports in the
future and and does your company enable
that even further exactly I mean
basically you can't do that unless you
capture the entire pitch create data
from the game that's the foundation for
being being able to create such
interactive experiences Patrick uh great
speaking to you thanks so much for
joining me thank you very much
now it's been nearly 10 years since the
collapse of the Rana Plaza Factory in
Bangladesh in which more than a thousand
people were killed the disaster inspired
the foundation of know the origin a hub
for sustainable products with traceable
Roots the company was wound down in the
wake of the cobit pandemic but has just
been brought back out of liquidation by
Rachel Watkin founder of the Tiny Box
Company and Rachel joins us now from her
main distribution centers thanks so much
for for joining me uh this morning so
just uh remind everyone exactly what
know your origin is is all about
good morning uh greetings from Sunny
Sussex uh so know the origin is like a
department store online at the moment uh
designed to provide sustainable and
ethical products that have full
traceability so people know what they're
buying it's clothing accessories beauty
products houseware and anything that
people would need for a house a mini
department store we're not quite John
Lewis size yet but hopefully in the
future
and and uh obviously as we mentioned in
the intro you've brought this this
company and this initiative uh out of
liquidation is there a greater need for
it than ever or is there at least some
Trend in place say over the last decade
where uh We've started to be a bit
better uh not exploiting either the
environment or workers in in certain
regards
I would love to say that it's getting
better
but you know the truth is that 10 years
after the the plaza disaster we are
still in a circle of fast fashion
disposable fashion disposable products
so the the idea of know the origin is to
make it more accessible you know if
people have a choice and we take the
pain point out of the of the of the um
of the buying process where they can
have easy access at reasonable prices
then hopefully we can stimulate change
but we've still got a long way to go
and and is the UK itself uh in a fairly
good position on this type of front uh
or or not versus uh other sort of
developed markets
so in lots of ways we're very behind
cause fast fashion is is it's consumed
it's such a high rate in this country
compared to some other countries the UK
and America are you know we consume it
far faster than the Scandinavia Germany
where they have a little more
responsibility shall we say
um I wanted to get your take as well on
on uh your your perspective is a very
successful UK entrepreneur with the Tiny
Box Company we saw this morning uh story
that AstraZeneca has committed to a big
new investment but in Ireland and said
that the UK was not conducive to to
Greater investment particularly on the
tax front here in the UK is that
something you agree with or do you think
it's a good place to to do business and
start companies
oh that's a tricky one
um I think part of it depends on what
type of business you're you're setting
up here uh you know as to what Finance
you have access to uh I think certainly
as a female entrepreneur it's a lot more
difficult in this country than some
other countries uh because of
unconscious bias and everything else you
know so it's less about the tax but it's
more about access to funding should we
say and then once you're more
established yes the the tax is quite
High here you know if you add
corporation tax dividend tax
uh yeah it's um it's challenging and and
do you think the last couple of years in
particular the environment's got tougher
uh well I was very surprised to hear on
the news this morning that when we're
technically in recession because yes the
trading uh every business that I speak
to you know we do clinics
um we speak to a lot of other businesses
a lot of people are struggling right now
so yeah that was surprising news for me
and uh if uh I wanted to touch as well
on uh a personal aspect of your story
because it's discussing all of these
these initiatives you're involved with
it it's somewhat amazing to me that
you've managed it all because you've had
an enormous amount on your plate I
believe and and uh recently uh I think
successfully baffled uh breast cancer
talk us through the uh how you managed
to juggle this extraordinary amount on
your plate
so first of all a fantastic team you
know I work with some brilliant people
secondly you know we moan about the NHS
what a fantastic Journey that I had I
was diagnosed in October with breast
cancer it was caught early uh I have a
genetic disorder so they suggested
straight away a double mistake to me
diagnosed on the 20th of October
operation 16th of December and you know
I'm seven weeks down the line and doing
great and when I say double mistake to
me they took everything my lymph nodes
you know
and you know that is down to a fantastic
NHS
well it's it's it's great to just hear
the the success story Rachel on your
personal health but uh when you tie it
into to on the business side and then uh
more altruistic Endeavors like know the
origin it's really an inspiring story so
congratulations and longwork continue
thanks for joining us thank you very
much thank you Rachel uh Watkin the
founder of Tiny Box Company and many
other things uh as we heard just there
[Music]
both the ft and uh the times uh uh both
uh business Pages include a story high
on the list uh on the fact that activist
investor Nelson Peltz is giving up on a
campaign that he had for a seat on the
board of Disney it comes of course after
Disney CEO Bob Iger laid out his plans
for the next few years uh since
returning to the helm uh earlier in the
week and it included some cost cutting
and profit focus of pelters dialed back
his attack on the uh the management of
Disney interestingly though yesterday
after the earnings call which was on
Wednesday evening when the stock
initially jumped over five percent
through the regular session in the U.S
yes they gave up all of those gains
perhaps just showing uh how nervous uh
Market investors are at the moment
initial good news evaporated by the end
of the session yesterday
also worth checking out a story tongue
of the US and earnings movers in the Ft
also on our sister station cnbc's
website uh Lyft uh their earnings were
reported last night uh Lyft of course is
a U.S Pure Play Ride sharing app which
basically operates as a duopoly in the
US with Uber and their Shares are down
some 30 percent uh overnight Uber had
strong numbers uh earlier in the week
which were largely welcomed by the
market Lyft could hardly be more
different worth checking those stories
out joining me now uh as ever on a
Friday is the financial markets
commentator and evening standard
columnist sir Neil Collins Neil very
good morning too thanks uh so much for
for joining me uh talk me through the
first uh the first story that's caught
your attention today
oh I I think that the the most
extraordinary one it was the
um the fine uh leaded by the EU
um to 2.3 billion
um and it looks to me as though they
thoroughly deserve we thoroughly
deserved our kicking
um because we were letting all this
Chinese good in at prices which were
clearly wrong they were far too low so
they avoided Duty so I think that's uh
that's pretty embarrassing for the
government and that was when we were in
the EU of course
um I dare say it'd be different this
time
um but I suppose we need to talk about
the um GNP figures even though they're
pretty dull I mean the UK economy has
sort of De calmed at the moment
um I think people don't really know
what's going to happen we're we're on
the edge of a technical recession but I
don't suppose people could tell the
difference between a technical recession
and a real recession all the real
recession probably worse
um I think that uh Neil I do think is is
that clearly as you say that this
technical recession just avoided uh
because the economy was flat as opposed
to declining now would need two fresh
quarters of declines to to trigger that
headline for the government or or
whatever we'd be focusing on and
actually the comps for the first half of
next year aren't too bad so the
government might possibly Escape ever
having to face that headline
uh that may be the case yes but I mean
the amounts are so small we're so close
to zero uh that
um some sort of obscure uh outside
influence like say a fall in the oil
price or a rise of mobile price could
make the difference between the the the
net position being plus or minus so I
think we're getting to the point we're
almost sort of uh angels dancing on the
head of a pin here
um you know the economy is not in good
shape and I think that uh much depends
on what happens with the budget next
month uh to see whether that will
produce the sort of increase in in
people's uh confidence I think is what's
needed rather than a sort of
crowd-pleasing uh technical budget which
cuts a few uh cuts a few
um taxes which which are rather than it
I'm sorry about this no don't worry at
all and I totally agree it's certainly
true that only the UK and Russia of the
G20 have economies that are still
smaller in absolute terms than their
their pre pre-pandemic levels one of the
other questions I just wanted to to get
your your view on is the sort of jitters
despite a strong rally in January that
we're seeing in in the U.S market I
mentioned Lyft overnight but perhaps
most interesting was Google over the
last two days has shed 150 billion
dollars in in market cap or all because
of the launch of the update to their
search engine underwhelmed a little bit
yes
um I don't think anybody really
understands
how much impact these uh second
generation uh search engines are going
to have
um I think that their capacity for
giving uh wrong answers on the you've
tried and tested principle of garbage in
garbage out
um they certainly haven't overcome that
yet
I think it was a bit of a shock to uh to
discover that Google which is a pretty
well run and impressive organization
could have made such an elementary
blunder with some of the answers I think
it was the one about uh whether the
telescope had found the first uh
non-solar system planet and it said yes
it had and that was the wrong answer
so it undermined The credibility of lots
of other answers and I think the
knock-on effect was was dramatic on the
share price don't forget these tech
companies are still hugely highly valued
very sensitive to any sort of change in
the Market's view of future prospects so
uh it's going to continue to be very
volatile Neil Collins thanks so much for
joining me this morning very much
appreciated as always I sort of come
here on Ian King live as the music
industry prepares to party at the Brit
Awards sir they're stepping up a fight
against piracy we'll be right back
[Music]
it's the biggest week of the year for
the British music industry we started
with the Grammys and tomorrow night the
Brit Awards will highlight current and
future UK talent but behind this weekend
star performances the industry is
fighting the twin problems of piracy and
theft and one British company wants to
lead the way in combating music Crime uh
joining me now is Nick Stewart chief
executive of the anti-piracy business
tcat also known as To Catch a Thief uh
Nick thanks so much for for joining me
so your company uh you have software
that it tries to track music piracy
that's right uh well we do
um tcat has two main products one is
called Street date which makes certain
that all the music that is put on the
dsps is actually up there there are 229
uh countries that have dsps and so we
track to make sure that music that
should be up there is there and then
we're able to fingerprint whether or not
there's been any infringement or any
piracy uh where a young
but we've had an enormous take up on the
products that we offer and I think is
one of the most significant pieces of
Technology since I've been involved in
the music business
and and clearly 10 20 years ago on
streaming and on digital music uh piracy
was a huge problem with with companies
like Napster most people assume because
the labels themselves have shifted to
embracing streaming that it's not much
of a problem today is the reality for me
well piracy is a is a factor Wilfred I
mean you know the office of um the IPO
have said that there's nine billion
pounds worth of business lost each year
through piracy and counterfeiting and it
results in a huge number of jobs being
lost I mean every day every day uh a
hundred thousand tracks globally get put
up on the dsps that's a Digital
streaming platforms that's Apple Amazon
these uh uh Spotify and the rest of it
and we track where for our clients where
that music is and whether it's up there
legally and and the rights holders are
being paid correctly
um just finally I apologies that we're a
little bit out of time but more broadly
uh we've seen an extraordinary inflation
value in in terms of Music rights and a
lot of artists selling their back
catalogs do you feel that that might
have peaked now in fact if you tighten
up on piracy perhaps it's got another
leg higher to go
it could do there's been some very
obviously hypnosis leading the way
primary wave as well
um there have been some very big catalog
sales and there's enormous value and
therefore it's up to the owners now of
the uh of these catalogs to make sure
that their music is protected and they
get paid correctly
um and we've only just begun but we're
making significant progress
next trip thanks so much for joining me
this morning very much appreciate it
chief executive uh of T cat uh we've got
about uh 30 seconds or so left in the
show just wanted to touch back on the
markets uh which have taken a little bit
of a turn uh south over the course of
the show these stocks 600 uh index in
Europe is now down a little more than uh
one percent uh whilst U.S Futures have
also worsened uh during the course of
the morning the NASDAQ the tech heavy
index in the US is expected to open Low
by almost one percent uh as things stand
the s p expected to open by about
0.4 percent meanwhile here in the UK the
ftse 100 down about 0.4 pulling back of
course from recent uh all-time highs
that does it for Ian King live today
thanks so much for watching
foreign
[Music]